I don't look like a comic I look like
I'm here to just to fix this microphone
I'm pretty sure I can't not look like
this I have to wear these clothes
because they match my face that's why I
wear these clothes I have manual-labor
face that's what it's called I have I'm
the head of the Union face I have I like
to fish on the weekends I know exactly
what I look like I'll tell you why
because the other day I walked into a
store and I saw two other fat bearded
guys and the minute I walked in the
store they both nodded at me at the same
time just like your home brother don't
worry about it this is your mothership
New York everybody how about you
Brooklyn is tough man I go to a thug
barbershop in my neighborhood I don't
you know that is the SUP barbershop is
the only place that you go to get your
hair cut and right after he's done the
guy who'd just cut your hair makes fun
of the haircut that he just did like the
other day got my hair cut and right
afterwards the guy looks at me goes oh
snap he goes you look like Bobby from
king of the hills you just did that that
was you your own professional this is
Brooklyn stuff plays dude like my friend
called me up the other day and he goes
hey Shaun you want to go halfsies on a
gun that's what he said to me and I said
no it's a gun it's not a plate of fries
we're not splitting a pizza it's a gun I
don't want to go halfsies on a gun with
you and then I wake up one night I'm
getting robbed and I'm like oh [ __ ] it's
not my week for the gun
I like doing this job man I'm good at
this job I sucked everything job that
I've had I was a doorman for a while I
got fired for being a doorman which is a
hard thing to do this is true I got
fired for leaving the door open that's
absolutely true that's half the job
right there I just hope they're doing
like too much pressure I can't handle
this I worked at a blockbuster for a
long time which is pretty much like
saying you were a blacksmith at this
point when you tell people you worked at
a blockbuster you might as well have
said 18th century gold prospector like I
kind of wish I had a more badass job you
know I'm saying but I think I look
tougher than I actually am but I met
this dude the other day he must have
been like 75 years old right and he
walks up to me and he goes like this
this is how he introduced himself he
walks up he goes Bill Thompson
construction 35 years you can only do
that if you have a badass job and you've
been there for a long time like I can't
walk up to you and go Sean Donnelly
sunglass hut nine weeks
I'm married but you guys I'm married I
like being married I want to have kids
but here's the deal I've been married
for like four years so when you're
married for a bit and you don't have
kids your friends who have them they try
to bully you into having kids they want
you to be as miserable as they are
that's why they're doing and they always
say the same thing they go there's never
a right time to have kids do it now
there's never a right time and maybe
that's true maybe that's true and
there's never a right time to have kids
but there's definitely a wrong time to
have this yeah like if you're still
paying for stuff with change that's a
wrong time you're buying sandwiches with
Sacagawea dollars we kind of have a kid
now we have an English bulldog you know
that is yeah yeah if you know what that
is those are dogs that are really fat
and they're low to the ground they have
breathing probably go huh nice cool I
just got the dog version of myself
that's basically what I just wanted
something else on a healthier than me in
my house you know I'm saying but I love
my dog I don't know if you know this
about English bulldogs they're very
stubborn dogs they like to pull you when
you want them and I spend all day with
my dog so sometimes I forget my dogs a
dog and I talk to like as a human you
know talking about the other day I'm
walking him and he's pulling me and out
of nowhere I just show that I go you
think you call the shots
well you don't I call the shots and then
he pooped and then I picked it up I
picked up the boom
I love my dog man I wish she was human
if he was human
give me the coolest guy in the world you
know I'm saying he'd be the kind of guy
you could crash his car he wouldn't give
a [ __ ] you know I mean didn't how many
times I've hit my dog in the head with
the door
and he's just like yeah it's totally
cool don't worry about it let's do
something else I love it's gonna die no
let's do whatever I don't care you can't
do that with cats let's face everybody
cats are jerks
okay yes if cats were human they would
just be like you're really uptight
skinny friend Beth then you can't say
the word and moist around